director paul thomas anderson's 1997
classic boogie nights takes the audience
on a vivid ride through the golden years
of the porn industry the story behind
the film however is almost as wild this
is the untold truth of boogie nights
paul thomas anderson's father ernie
guillardi anderson began his career in
the 1960s as a cleveland television
horror movie host however he eventually
found success as a hollywood voice
artist counting comedians actors and
other hollywood types among his friends
ernie had worked with tim conway at wjw
tv in cleveland in the 60s conway left
to star in mchale's navy but eventually
ernie joined him in los angeles and the
rest is history according to esquire
ernie eventually bought a big house in
the san fernando valley where he would
frequently play host to his various
funny friends like conway and actor
harvey corman both of whom had a flare
for twisted humor for paul's 12th
birthday ernie bought him a betamax
camcorder with the camcorder in hand
paul went on to make vignettes that
followed his father and his zany
hollywood friends according to esquire
hall's father likely inspired burt
reynolds jack horner and boogie night
there were other inspirations as well as
paul explained to the philadelphia city
paper growing up in the san fernando
valley porn was always around there were
these industrial looking buildings with
no signage but you'd see people going in
and out you knew what they were doing
anderson has been described by many of
the people involved in boogie nights as
looking like a kid when they first met
him which makes sense since he was 26 at
the time that he was looking to helm his
first big hollywood feature however
anderson had already made one movie
about dirk in the porn industry when he
was still in high school that film the
dirk diggler story was a visual first
draft for what he would finally realize
in boogie nights according to
grantland.com's oral history of the
movie paul thomas anderson claims to
have had an epiphany about the name dirk
digler at 17. he then wrote the name on
a piece of paper and began putting
together a student film using a
camcorder and a steadicam anderson
pulled together his friends to play dirk
reed and various others in the low
budget film he did have one star
involved though his dad ernie
back in the 90s john lesher was a
powerful talent agent one of his clients
was harmony kareem a talented young
writer whose career began when he wrote
kids at age 19. as deadline explained in
a 2013 article lesser championed kareem
for years while an agent at uta and
endeavour and leisure continued that
support as a producer yet lesher had
another wunderkind client at the time
paul thomas anderson michael deluca an
exec at new line cinema at the time told
grant land i was talking with john
lescher about the movie kids i passed
when he brought it to new line just as a
joke i said to him don't let me pass on
something this cool again and later john
said remember when you said don't let
you pass on something cool lesha then
described in the article how he met
deluca for drinks gave him the script
for boogie nights and the next day they
were in business according to
entertainment journalist sharon waxman
another reason for deluca to pick up
boogie nights may have been that he was
a quote bad boy at the time waxman told
grantland michael deluca loved that life
and he lived that life whether it was
good agenting or simply a case of party
boy meets party script it seems as
destined as dirk digler for greatness
at 23 anderson got into the sundance
film festival with his short film
cigarettes and coffee the following year
anderson came back to the sundance lab
and expanded on cigarettes and coffee
with his first feature heart eight paul
thomas anderson titled it sydney when he
first conceived the idea in high school
the idea for the film came after he
watched a short philip baker hall scene
as a consigliere named sydney in
midnight run sydney was anderson's
working title for the film and he was
infuriated when his backers took final
cut and the name away from him the movie
had a budget of 3 million dollars and
starred hall and john c riley as the
leagues gwyneth paltrow and samuel
jackson as top supporting actors plus
philip seymour hoffman early in his
career for a debut film from a 25 year
old kid heart 8 notched great reviews
and paved the way for anderson's first
studio feature the budget for boogie
nights was 15 million dollars and there
were more actors in sets but hall riley
and hoffman all returned to work with
anderson on a movie that would help
propel the careers of all four
despite the fact that the movie was an
at times depressing story about the porn
industry a lot of actors were circling
the script according to grant land's
oral history drew barrymore was roller
girl at one point the role of director
producer jack horner however was offered
to a lot of big talent bill murray
harvey keitel sydney pollock and albert
brooks were supposedly all offered the
role but paul thomas anderson discussed
it extensively with warren beatty i got
to know warren
many years ago about 20 years ago when i
was
going to do boogie nights i sent him the
script and asked him to be in it as
anderson said in an interview with
charlie rose warren had shown a lot of
interest in playing the part of jack
horner however anderson ultimately made
a realization that beatty didn't
necessarily want to play the director
anderson told grantland i started to
figure out that warren really wanted to
play dirk diggler mark wahlberg you
don't really want to play jack horner
you want to be the kid in this movie he
said yeah horner eventually went to burt
reynolds and it's hard now imagining
anybody else playing it though it
appears that reynolds brought quite a
few challenges to the production
in an interview with gq burt reynolds
was asked if he'd worked with anderson
again his answer i don't think so
personality wise we didn't fit according
to the grant land oral history there was
even a moment when anderson gave
reynolds perhaps less respect than he
deserved and it supposedly came to blows
burt reynolds clarified to conan o'brien
that he hadn't punched anderson but
wanted to i don't want to hit him in the
face
i just wanted to hit him
according to the hollywood reporter's
obituary for the actor reynolds was so
unhappy with the film and his place in
it that he fired his agent after seeing
it for the first time it was ironic then
that he won his only film golden globe
for his turn as jack horner plus he was
nominated for the best supporting actor
oscar although he eventually lost to
robin williams for his turn in goodwill
hunting
one of the most intense scenes in boogie
nights occurs towards the end when dirk
reed played by john c reilly and todd
parker played by thomas jane are sitting
in the living room of a crazy rich man's
house looking to rip him off by selling
him some fake dope in the scene there's
a random voyages walking around throwing
firecrackers at the floor many of the
casts recalled how that was the craziest
scene in the whole film and in large
part that was due to the unexpected
randomness of the constant mini
explosions director robert downey senior
said in grant land's oral history that
idea came from a scene in my movie
putney swope it's one of paul's
favorites my thing was the asian guy
who's throwing around firecrackers and
just doesn't say a word another
inspiration though was anderson's father
according to esquire ernie anderson
liked tossing firecrackers around so
there you have it two showbiz fathers
with a fondness for firecrackers
inspired one of the most insane scenes
in a movie full of intense sequences
a few characters or at least character
names made it to boogie knights from the
dirk dickler story one of those is reed
rothschild dirk's best friend in the
porn industry in the original though
reed was very different reed was played
by eddie dilcore a bodybuilder who was
also dirk's lover in that original
iteration del core features prominently
in the student film since he was dirk's
best friend there's even a scene where
they're both together in a hot tub while
the romantic element of the dirk reed
relationship didn't make it into boogie
nights one del core item did reid's hot
tub poem according to the oral history
del core was constantly trying to get
anderson to crack up on the set and was
even invited to be in boogie night
however by that point del cor had begun
his career as a christian minister which
would have been tough to square with a
film about drugs and porn one of his
improvisations was the poem that john c
reilly recites as reed while in the hot
tub with dirk it's a poem about love and
honey trees and bees one so bad yet so
amazing because of how well it sets up
the duo's rock solid friendship
i love you
you love me
going down the sugar tree did you write
that yeah i write songs too
anderson had been making movies since he
was 12 and some of those early ones were
actually scripted films in fact
anderson's early films all seemed to
march toward what he would eventually
realize in hard 8 and boogie nights
obviously the dirk digler story is a
major stepping stone from the tale of
dirk's rise and fall to the fact that
recording the touch was featured in both
as an example of dirk's failed second
career but according to esquire it
becomes striking how much of these films
began when anderson was still too young
to actually buy pornography esquire
mentions how anderson first told the
teacher he was going to make a movie
called sydney based solely on the
snippet of philip baker hall he'd seen
in midnight run as a young teen however
he made a miami vice parody called brock
landers which went on to be the name of
dirk's monumental x-rated action series
does this character have a name
his name
is brock landers
anderson also made a young guns parody
called young buns with erotic undertones
if nothing else anderson was a student
of film from a very early age and didn't
just want to watch them but wanted to be
part of them as well
john holmes was a very successful adult
film actor known for having a heavy drug
addiction and eventually his possible
role in the wonderland murders according
to esquire paul thomas anderson told a
friend in high school that the idea for
his next movie was inspired by the sad
life of holmes in a 1997 interview with
philadelphia city paper anderson
explained how dirk's career was very
similar to that of holmes with the 80s
and the drugs everything's taken a toll
on him that happened in john holmes's
life and it was reflected in the
character he played johnny watt we did
the same thing with dirk and in the
movie i blame the drugs and ego building
in that same interview he also
specifically mentions the early johnny
wad films as examples of great
storytelling in porn there was also a
john holmes documentary called exhausted
that was one of the inspirations for
anderson to shoot the dirk diggler story
as a mockumentary it was such a big
inspiration that the documentary was
even an added feature on a criterion
laserdisc of boogie night with anderson
pointing out in the commentary how the
film was a quote major influence
a final shocking fact to come out of
boogie nights is that its star a man
still known at the time as an underwear
model in teen idol called marky mark has
said that he probably wouldn't do boogie
nights again despite having just a few
acting credits at the time yes mark
wahlberg said in a 2017 appearance that
he hopes god forgives him for his poor
acting choices and that boogie knights
is at the top of the list there was a
lot of outcry about him negating the
movie that gave him serious acting cred
as julianne moore put it to andy cohen i
think he should thank god for boogie
nights
yes
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff for coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you